i'm not recommending you cut school to
go to trunk shows or fashion shows but
i did a little bit of that when i was
younger too
by sharing what i know i hope that it
will inspire you to
create and express yourself through
fashion
my grandmother would buy me vogue french
vogue sometimes if i was really lucky
i would just pour over these images that
was my first introduction to fashion
i'll be discussing things that i wish i
knew starting out
the heart of my class is sharing the
technical process
once in a while it's a fabric that
inspires the dress
and other times it's the dress we want
to make that inspires the fabric
this is called intarsia when the fabric
is not
appliqued it is actually pieced together
almost like a jigsaw puzzle
a nice juxtaposition of finishing
something beautifully
and then leaving edges of the fabric
frayed
the runway show is very important to me
it can transmit
not only ideas about texture
and proportion but also about spirit
and emotion i was brought into louis
vuitton
to shake things up and it didn't always
sit well with the people who were there
before me a lot of the ideas that i had
early on i was told you can't put this
on the runway
and it really was when i stopped
listening to everybody and did what i
thought was right
that i did what i was brought in to do
but i personally
feel good when i take a risk i'm proud
of myself when i take a chance
i think you should too i hope you learn
fashion is not an art it's part of the
art of living see what you really love
what you feel you have some kind of
connection to
create your own voice your own vision
your own style
taking creative risks is what fashion is
about
i'm marc jacobs and this is my master
class
you